[Musica]
buonasera ho ascoltato attentamente i
relatori che mi hanno preceduto e prova
a riportare l'uomo al centro prove
riportare l'uomo al centro perché tutto
ciò di cui ho sentito e parleremo e
cercare di crearci un futuro migliore un
futuro dove miglioriamo le efficienze
miglioriamo i livelli di sicurezza ma
miglioriamo le efficienze e livelli di
sicurezza per migliorare la vita
dell'uomo e quindi più che parlare di e
motion
vorrei parlarvi anche di e motion perché
se è vero che sarà possibile guardare
dentro un frigorifero e quindi capire se
manca qualcosa in un frigorifero è pur
vero che mi piacerebbe poter guardare
dentro nel frigorifero che era vuoto e
poi magari vederlo pieno e poter
ringraziare chi mi ha riempito il
frigorifero
mi piacerebbe che potessi ringraziare
una persona e quindi esprimere le mie di
e motion
se è vero che mi piacerebbe poter essere
aiutato nel guidare la mia macchina da
un robot perché sicuramente più sicuro
ed efficiente della guida di un umano è
altrettanto vero che non vorrei che un
giorno fosse un robot che mi dava una
carezza un robot che mi dà un bacio
questo non lo voglio e penso che se
chiedessi ognuno di voi se vuole che il
progresso sia in funzione dell'uomo e
non più l'uomo che diventa quasi un
funzionario del progresso
penso che la stragrande maggioranza di
voi continui a pensare che il bacio lo
vuole dalla sua amata o dal suo amato e
il vostro figlio la carezza la vuole da
voi e non da un robot
per creare un futuro dove l'uomo trova
il centro di sicuro bisogna muoversi e
non solo stare seduti ad aspettare che
qualcuno lo cambi per noi ci hanno detto
che un giorno arriverà qualcuno che
cambierà il mondo io non so se gli
stiamo facendo bene in voglia di tornare
e cambiarselo o se dobbiamo tirarci
sulle mani le maniche cambiarselo noi e
quindi diventare noi i protagonisti del
proprio futuro perché se è vero che la
robotica
se è vero che qualsiasi device ci hanno
cambiato e di molto e solitamente è
meglio la nostra vita
anch'io ho uno smartphone di ultima
generazione anch'io vado in macchina
anch'io mi sposto con tutti i mezzi
meccanici che l'uomo è inventato mi sono
accorto nel mondo che ho scelto io di
vivere è che tutto questo funziona oggi
se la batteria funziona e se ciò ancora
batteria
se ciò ancora benzina se c'è ancora luce
e se qualcuno di questi alimenti di
questo futuro smette di colpo tutto
ritorna nelle nostre mani
mani che non dobbiamo prendere e
assumersi il rischio di perdere
l'utilizzo l'uomo ritorna al centro
l'uomo deve tornare ad arrangiarsi e
questa è un'arte che non dobbiamo
perdere pensando e guardando solo al
futuro
io faccio un lavoro che molti penseranno
sia stupido scala le montagne da scalare
una montagna non cambia la storia del
pianeta come può cambiarla magari la
scoperta di una cura o di una medicina
per tutti quelli che nel passato nel
presente e nel futuro hanno cambiato la
storia del pianeta si sono messi in
cammino non mossi da una passione ma
prima ancora mossi da un sogno e quindi
essere appassionati dannatamente
appassionati del proprio sogno
io ho portato un video brevissimo che
direi che possiamo vedere il mandare
adesso questi sono due uomini spogliati
di tutta la tecnologia che si muovono a
piedi alle quote di volo di un jumbo qui
siamo solo a 7200 metri 56 gradi sotto
zero
qui nessuno parla nessuno guarda uno
smartphone
qui nessuno è seduto di fronte alla
console di una qualsiasi in un qualsiasi
mezzo meccanico
qui l'unica benzina che sia è la tua
e quello che si sta facendo e cercare di
raggiungere dopo oltre tre decenni di
tentativi la montagna più grande del
pianeta in pieno inverno
vedete qui nessuno parla sapete perché
perché non si sa neppure la forza di
parlare non si hanno le energie per
farlo
e qui l'intesa è a gesti qui ci stiamo
attrezzando l'ultimo campo a 7200 metri
per prepararsi a quella che il giorno
successivo diventerà la prima salita
della storia di un uomo sulla vetta del
nanga parbat 8.125 metri
qui che ottimizza il tuo sforzo non è un
computer ma è la tua capacità interiore
di conoscerti ed è anche la capacità di
riconoscere qual è l'obiettivo
qual è il traguardo
non penserete che il traguardo sia la
vetta la vetta esattamente metà del
percorso che devi percorrere e quindi
devi sapere
in queste condizioni con un quarto
dell'ossigeno rispetto a quello che
stiamo respirando noi adesso qual è il
limite con cui tu ti puoi spingere in
alto senza ossigeno a quelle temperature
e avere ancora le capacità sempre tu a
piedi di poter ritornare al campo base
che è invece il vero obiettivo il vero
traguardo
ebbene questo è un modo lento di
spostarsi ed un modo antico di spostarsi
lo stesso modo con cui i grandi
esploratori del passato hanno esplorato
hanno scoperto hanno visitato tutti gli
angoli remoti del pianeta
molti di questi addirittura non hanno
fatto spostamenti movimenti motion con
il proprio corpo con una manifestazione
muscolare l'hanno fatto con la mente mi
viene in mente anche leonardo da vinci
chi fuori ho visto che c'è un paracadute
attaccato al soffitto e viene pensato
che quel paracadute come un elicottero
come tante altre invenzioni leonardo da
vinci le penso quasi 500 anni fa quando
non c'era nessun tipo di tecnologia ma
l'uomo e la mente erano al centro e si
era questa capacità visionaria di
pensare qualcosa che non fosse neppure
nell'immaginario collettivo il mio modo
di spostarmi è stato ed è ancora oggi
principalmente in questo modo ho fatto
circa 55 spedizioni mi è piaciuto vedere
la fotografia della vetta delle palestre
nel primo intervento in cima alla valle
si sono stato quattro volte e la fortuna
di un cosmonauta di vedere la linea
dell'orizzonte così curva io non l'ho
avuta ma vi posso dire che sulla cima
dell'everest
ho visto la curva dell'orizzonte ho
visto il pianeta e ho portato a casa non
tanto un successo ma la stessa identica
sensibilità che ho sentito nelle parole
del primo relatore dove è tornato non
con una sensazione di onnipotenza di
grandezza ma di e motion di una grande
emozione che si chiama amore per ciò che
ha visto da lontano dal quale si era
allontanato consapevolmente e dal quale
è tornato cambiato da quel viaggio
ebbene noi che parliamo di tecnologie
parliamo di robotica parliamo di un
futuro che vogliamo e dobbiamo cambiare
però mi piacerebbe che nello cambiassimo
sempre ricordandosi che tutto ciò che
inventiamo tutto ciò che concepiamo non
deve mirare solo a un progresso fine a
se stesso ma un progresso che non solo
ci migliori la vita ma percorso che
riporti al centro perché il progresso
avrà avuto un senso di esistere se alla
fine noi non saremmo solo degli uomini
progrediti ma dagli uomini progrediti
che saranno ancora felici grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]